Stable equilibrium.
Then if you disturb them,
bed rock back and forth and there's two simple examples.
The Standard Textbook example is this mass in spring.
This spring has a certain natural linked which I'm showing you here.
It likes to sit there but if you pull it for the mass comes here,
you move it from x equals zero to the new location x.
Then that is a distorting force F which is minus Kx
and that force would it be equal to mass times acceleration by Newton's law
and so you have tried to solve the equation.
The two x over d d squared equals minus
K O and m
time sex and we used the symbol or may go square equalsK or whatever.
I'd Omega is quite okay with it and what's the solution?
This equation,
I think we did a lot of talking and said,
look,
we are looking for a function which when differentiated twice looks like the
same function up to some constants and we know their trigonometry functions.
Then we finally found the answer for most general answer looks like a co sine
Omega t minus five is the amplitude phase called the phase that tells you what
your clock is doing when x is a maximum.
And we can always choose fight to be zero.
That means we,
the time is zero X.
We'll have a biggest value a,
this is an example of simple harmonic motion,
but it is very generic situation.
So I gave you a second example.
Not we don't have a mass.
Uh,
we have a bar,
let's say suspended by a cable hanging from the ceiling
and it's happy the way it is.
But if you come and twisted by an angle Taito give it a little twist,
then it'll try to untwist itself.
So no,
we don't have a distorting force,
but we have a restoring torque.
Okay?
What can be the expression for the restoring torque?
When you don't do anything,
it doesn't do anything.
So it's a function of data that vanishes when data is zero.
If data is not zero,
it'll begin as some function of paper with the leading trend would be this data.
But now you can put a constant here.
It'll still be proportional.
The data and you put a minus sign for the same reducing and put a minus sign
here to tell you is the restoring torque.
That means if you make the deposit to the torque will try to twist you the other
way to make that a negative and try to bring you back so you have to find this
kappa.
If you find this cap on,
then you can say minus cap four times data is I times Steve to take over DT
square mathematically equation is identical to that and data.
Then we'll look like some constant,
you can call it a core sine omega t minus fi and omega.
No would be the ratio of this cap on the moment of inertia because
mathematically that's the role played by cap and I [inaudible].
Okay.
No,
because someone tells you this is kappa,
then you're done.
You just stick it in and mindlessly calculate all the formulas.
You can find data,
you can take directives and so on.
Sometimes they may not tell you what kappa is.
In the case of a spring,
they would have to give you a K odd.
They may tell you in directly,
if I pull the spring by nine inches,
I exerted a certain force.
They'd given you f and that giving you x and you can find k but in rotation
problems,
the typical situation is the following.
Let us take
the easiest problem of a pendulum.
The pendulum is hanging,
say a mass list ride with some mass and my the bottom
so it's very happy to stay this way.
If you leave it like this,
if you stay this way forever,
no tarp,
no motion.
Now you come along and you disturb that by turning it by an angle data.
If you do,
then the force is like this.
The separation vector are from the pivot point.
Is this an autocross f we'd be non zero because the angle between them is not
zero and did remember the Torque is equal to r f sine theta and I totally for
small angles,
this can be sub r,
f theta
and art.
It happens to be in this problem,
the length of the pendulum,
so it's really minus m g l data,
so you have to do some work to find data.
It wasn't just given to you in a plate.
You did this piece of thinking and you namely,
you disrupt the system from equilibrium and found the restoring torque.
Then you stare at the formula and say,
Hey,
this guy must be the cap I'm looking for because that number times data is the
restoring torque.
Then the Omega here will be this cap.
I said January kappa,
that goes into whatever it is for that problem.
For our problem.
CAPRA happens to be MGL.
That's something you should understand.
It's not a universal number.
That's a known to everybody.
Like the spring constant of anything.
In the case of mass and this your lump,
it depends on how long the pendulum is,
how big the masses,
but you can work it out and extract kappa.
Don't stay as you need a moment to finish.
Yeah.
What a point mass m octa distance l from the point of rotation,
it just ml square.
So you can cancel the l,
you can cancel the m and you get Omegas root of g over F
and I didn't mind you guys.
That Omega is connected to what you and I would call the frequency by there's
two pie f are what you and I would call the time period,
like two Pi over t.
Okay.
Okay,
so this is the situation.
Let me give one other example than,
I don't know this at a homework problem,
but I wanted to give you a hint on how to do this.
Don't take a pendulum with all the mass concentrated there.
Fix some irregularly shaped object flat or object.
You drive a nail through it,
they're hanging on the wall.
It'll come to rest in a certain configuration and you can use your think about
where will the center of Mass B,
if I hang it like this on the wall,
Tetra Mass,
somewhere in the body here.
So I want you to think about it.
I'll tell you in a second.
The center of mass I claim will lie somewhere on this vertical line.
Going through that point,
I know that by default because the center of mass,
but here for example,
we know all the force of gravity can be imagined to be acting here.
Then if you do that separation and do the Torque,
then you will find this is able to exert a target on this point,
but that cannot be an equilibrium,
so the center of mass will always lie.
We'll align yourself.
The body will swing a little bit and settle down the center of mass somewhere
there.
If you're not,
disrupt the body.
I don't want to draw another picture,
but I'd probably fail.
This is rotated body off from its ideal position.
Then that will be a torque.
What would the tarp be?
It the same thing minus m g l sine theta with where did he place by Tara eldest.
Now the distance between the pivot point and the center of mass,
that's your top
so you can read the cap way.
In fact,
it's just like the pendulum.
Another way.
As far as the Torque is concerned,
it's as if all the masks were sitting here.
The difference would be in moment of finish,
you want me to finish?
You have,
this is not emo squares.
Don't make the mistake.
All the masses not sitting here,
all the masters sitting all over the place.
So you should know that.
If you want a moment to finish.
Yeah,
it is.
I did respect the center of mass plus this ml square back to the old paddle
Alexis theater.
So take that moment of inertia,
put that into this formula here,
dig this Camba cappa and put it there and you'll get some frequency.
That's the frequency with your philosophy.
Every problem that you would ever get,
we look like one of these two,
eight that or something moving linearly with the coordinator that you can call x
audits,
rotating or twisting by an angle.
You can call data.
And if you want to find out the of vibration,
you have to disturb it from equilibrium,
either by pulling the massive,
by twisting the cable or displacing this pendulum from its ideal position here.
Then finding the restoring torque.
Yep.
That's a very good point.
His question is if I give you a cable and I twist the cable by some angle,
how about are we going to calculate restoring torque?
Here's the good news.
This problem is so hard,
we will give it to you.
In other words,
that is of course an underlying answer given a cable made of some material.
Andrew starshine would properties how much of a park you'll get if you twisted
by some amount,
but it's not something you can calculate from first principles,
so they will simply have to give it to you.
Okay?
In such problems,
the only time you will have to find the torque on your own isn't a problem like
this where I believe you don't enough to figure out the torque.
Okay?
What you will find this,
if you leave it alone,
it'll go to a position where there is no torque.
If you move it off that position,
that will be a torque and the torque will always be proportional.
The angle by which you displaced it,
you read up the proportionality constant and that's your capital.
By the way,
this is not a problem.
You should look at the forces to,
which is pretty interesting.
This body,
even there's hanging in its rest position has to forces on it.
The nail which is pushing up and the weight of the body,
which is pushing down and they canceled each other.
The nail will keep it from falling.
The nail will not keep it from swinging because the force of the nail acting as
a does at the pivot point is unable to exert a torque.
Whereas the minute you rotate the body mg is able to exert a park.
That's why if you twist it and you start rattling back and forth.
Alright,
so what I'm going to do now is to go over a more complicated oscillations
using some of the techniques we learned last time.
So here is the mega formula.
I'm going to give it to you guys.
You have to,
you're allowed to tattoo it on your face.
You can carry it with you.
I will allow you to bring it.
But you cannot forget this formula.
I think you know the Formula I'm driving at ready
eat the I x or 10 I don't care.
Let me call it data.
Here is consigned data plus I signed data.
That's the great formula from oiler
from this formula.
If you take the complex conjugate abode sites,
that means change every EIT to minus sign you would get either.
The minus I data is coastline data minus I assigned table.
That also you should know
if you got this in your head.
By the way,
this is something you're not going to derive on the spot.
It takes a lot of work,
so there's something.
If you,
if you tell me what are the few things you really have to cram that you don't
want the caddy in your head.
Well,
this is one of them,
okay?
This is a formula worth memorizing.
Unlike formula number 92 of your texts,
it's not worth memorizing.
This is worth memorizing.
Once you got this,
you should realize that in any expression involving complex numbers,
you can get another equation where every I is changed to minus side that can
give you this one that's called complex conjugation.
Identical.
He said,
if you have a complex number,
Z,
z scar is equal to x minus Y,
Z is equal x plus y.
So in our simple example,
this fellow here,
the Z,
this is the x and this is the why
not.
You should be able to invert this formula to invert the formula.
You add the two and divide by two,
then you will find co signed data is either the ITA topless in the minus I
theater over too.
If you subtract and divide by two I will find scientists.
Even the I data minus the minus I did over two I in other words,
my claim is that this funny exponential summer to expeditions is the family.
Of course sign,
it'll do everything.
Your coastline will do lansulate science,
square plus course and square would be one.
It'll satisfy all the tech non metric identities like signed to Taylor's do.
Scientist are constituted.
Everything comes out of this expression.
So you should know.
Here's the main point.
You should learn.
We don't need trigonometry functions anymore.
Once you got the exponential function provided,
you will let the exponent B complex or imaginary.
You don't need trigonometry functions.
This is one example of grand unification.
People always say,
Max will unify this and I am and try to unify this.
Unification means things that you taught but unrelated are in fact related and
there are different manifestations of the same thing.
When we first discovered ergonometric functions,
you know we were drawing try right angle triangles and opposite side in our days
and site.
Then we discover the exponential function,
which by the way was computed by bankers who were trying to calculate compound
interest.
Everybody is second.
The fact that those functions that relate to this a marvelous result,
but it happens only if you go to complex numbers.
So this is another thing you should know.
Yeah,
okay.
Now armed with this,
we already
do anything we want.
Let me just tell you that every complex number z can it and this is absolute
value times some phase.
In other words,
if my complex numbers,
these,
here it is x plus y,
y,
that's one way to write it.
You can also write it as an absolute value.
You're the Ifi,
are you to the Ifi artists,
the length.
It also happens to be the length of the complex number.
That's called the polar form of the complex number.
Explicit.
Why is the Cartesian form of the complex number
I may have called them out and data are in fight.
I just don't remember.
I'm going to use these symbols back and forth because people do use both.
The symbol,
which is why I am sometimes calling this angle is data.
Sometimes this angle is fine,
but the basic idea is the same.
This entity here can get and either in this form on in this one,
this is something you should know.
If you don't know or don't understand,
you should stop and ask.
Everything is built on this,
so what I'm going to do now is to go back to this rather simple equation.
Two x over d t square
equal to minus Omega Squared X.
By the way,
today I'm going to call this Omega as Omega not.
It's the same guy.
I'm going to call it Omega not because we will find as the hour progresses that
are going to be many Omegas in the game to more Omega [inaudible] going to come
in,
so we gotta be able to tell them apart.
As long as there's only one omega in town,
you just call it omega.
If there are many,
you call this Omega not demean is the frequency of vibration of the system left
to its own design and you pull it and let it go.
What's the frequency or angular frequency?
That's what we call Omega,
not now.
How did we solve this equation?
The way I tried to solve with for you is to say trinity,
the word problem.
I'm looking for a function x of t with a property.
The two directors or the function look like the function and we rake the reigns
a bit remembered,
hey,
science and coastlines are the property one day there's no good turn.
Sign it the coastline to derivatives bring back the function you started with,
which is why the answer could be science of course science,
but now I'm going to solve it in a different way.
My thinking is going to be,
I know a function that repeats itself even when a differentiated,
once
namely the function has a property.
It's first did a bit too.
It looks like the function itself,
it's obvious that is 90 secondary,
but it will also look like the function because taking the derivative leaves the
function alone except for pulling out some numbers.
So why not say I want an answer that looks like this.
X equals some a.
You're the Alpha t
that's certainly has the property that if you take do a little bit,
if it's going to look like you're the Alpha t on the left hand side and even on
foot on the right hand side and then you can cancel them and you've got yourself
a solution.
Do you guys remember why I didn't follow this
solution for the oscillator?
Why was it rejected?
Yes.
Sick.
Ah,
that's a very good point.
So maybe I will take either the minus Alpha I bought that.
Will that give me a second bit of it.
Do which just negative.
You didn't fall for that,
right?
Because first time we get minus Alpha,
but second time you'll get plus Alpha square that's connected.
This function is no good.
Also,
it doesn't look like what I want even without being much mathematical physics.
I know if you pull this spring is going to go back and forth,
but at these functions that exponentially growing,
that exponentially falling.
There's this don't do the trick,
but now we'll find that if you're willing to work with complex exponentials,
this will do the job.
So we just going to take the guess and put it in the equation and see if I can
get an answer that works.
Okay.
This is called an anzacs on Zach,
something we use all the time.
It's a German word.
I'm not sure exactly what it means,
but we all use it to mean attempted to guess.
That's what it is.
If you're lucky,
it'll work.
If I'm not lucky,
that's fine.
You move on and try another solution to.
We are going to say a solution of this form be found with a an Alpha completely
free.
Maybe the equation will tell me what a and l four should be.
So let's take it,
put it here.
By the way,
I'm going to write this equation and a form that's a little easier.
Xw God is minus Omega Zero squared expert.
each.is a derivative.
It's just more compact that way,
that rather than to write all of this stuff.
So let's take that guests and put it here and see what we get.
I get,
but I take two derivatives.
Uh,
you can say,
do I want eat the alpha minus Alpha t you will find it doesn't matter because
I'm going to take either the Alpha t and put a day.
No.
The beauty of the x function now is take one derivative X.
Dot.
I hope everybody knows the extra.
This is a,
you're the Alpha t and x double doc is another alpha,
a Alpha squared.
It'd the Alpha p.
That's the beauty of the explanation.
The act of differentiation is trivial.
You just multiply by the exponent Alpha.
So this being the result of taking two derivatives,
uh,
let me write it here.
Now what do I get?
So I'm going to go to x double dot equal to minus Omega zero squared x into
that.
I'm going to put in the guest's x equals either the Alpha t and what do I find?
I find that it's a live,
in fact,
let me write the equation in a nicer way.
X double.plus Omega zero squared x has to vanish.
I just brought everything to one side.
Not put either the Alpha t eight the Alpha t as your guests.
Then you find there's Alpha square a in the alpha.
Bless Omega zero squared a,
you're the Alpha t has to be zero.
Yeah,
so we know what to do.
Let's grow up a few terms.
This means you get a Phams Alpha squared plus one ear to the Alpha t has to
vanish.
If you can make that happen,
you've got a solution because you satisfy the equation.
No one's going to say,
well,
you got it.
Big guess work well.
It turns out solving differential equations is only guesswork.
There's no other way to solve the equation other than to make a guess,
stick it in food with the parameters,
see if it'll work.
So we're not done yet because we want this to vanish.
How many ways are that to kill this answer?
You can say maybe a zero.
A zero.
You've got watch color.
Trivial solution.
Yes.
Ah,
yes.
Thank you.
Yep.
Thank you very much.
This one is Alpha Square,
Rose Omega Zero Square.
Does everybody follow that?
Yes.
From here to here.
It's very clear what to do so we cannot kill a
yup.
[inaudible].
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm trying to rule out certain options.
I don't like the option.
I don't like to get this to be zero.
It's to say that the zero,
that's not happening either.
The outfit t is not going to vanish.
Maybe it advantage,
uh,
for some negative infinity time.
But I want this to be true at all times.
The equation has to be obeyed at all times.
Will this guy certainly is not zero at all time.
The only way to fix that as to have Alpha Square was Omega Zero Square equals
zero.
That's the only solution which is not a trivial solution.
Well that's the simple equation,
right?
It's a quadratic equation that mean Alpha squared is minus Omega Zero Square are
Alpha is plus or minus I Omega Zero.
So when we were young and we didn't know about complex numbers,
we will come to this state and we will quit and say,
look,
exponentials won't work.
But now we're not afraid of complex exponentials.
So we embraced the solution.
So now I have got two solutions.
By the way,
what's the value of a think about this.
If this condition is satisfied,
you realize it can be whatever you like is completely arbitrary.
So what this equation has told me is the following.
Yes that our solutions of this form for a,
you can pick any number you like.
In fact real a of complex.
It doesn't matter the equation,
dissatisfied what your Alpha is not an arbitrary number.
It can be only one of two numbers.
Plus I omega zero minus Iomega zero.
So we got a problem.
Now that I look at one answer,
I got to.
So I a ride them both.
Let's say that's the solution x one of t we did some number a eat to the eye
omega zero t.
Then I got another solution x two FT,
which is equal to any other number B e to the minus I Omega is either t
no.
I think you guys can see in your head that if you take this and you put it in
the equation,
it works and if we take this and put it into the equation,
that also works because when you take two derivatives Iomega whole square would
be minus Omega Square minus,
Oh I Iomega not holds had also be minus.
We'll make an arch queer,
so both will work.
No,
we have to ask,
how do I decide between that solution and that solution?
It turns out that we don't have to pick.
We can pick both and I'll tell you what I mean by we can pick both.
Oh,
this is a very,
very important property for all of you are going into economics or engineering
or chemistry.
This are other disciplines which are mathematical.
The property I'm going to mention off this equation is very important,
so please pay attention.
This is called a linear equation.
Linear equation.
We'll a certain property called super position.
I'll have to tell you what it is.
If I give you a differential equation,
you know 96 did ever do have x plus 52 times the 37 deliberate about bags
Blahblahblah adds up to zero.
What makes it a linear equation is that throughout an equation a that you find
the function x audits,
derivatives but never the squares or cubes that are higher powers of x or the
it,
okay,
the function appears the first power,
not the second power,
but example,
if this were the question you were trying to solve,
that is not a linear equation.
That's called a nonlinear equation.
If you have a linear equation,
that's a very,
very profound consequence and I'm going to tell you what it is and that lies at
the heart of so many things we do.
So let me write down two solutions.
One of them will be is x one double doc,
let's Omega naught squared x one equals zero second one over x to double dark.
It was Omega notch squared x week with a zero.
Don't even have to look at these two solutions.
Take a dental problem,
but you have a linear equation that are two solutions at the two equations
on the lefthand side.
I get the second or the of x one plus the second day they will do a vix.
Do I remember that is in fact the second did of it.
Do I like go back to the old rotation of x one plus x two this has to do with
the fact that database Dubois for Psalm,
it's a psalm of the databases and some of the data,
but it was the date of it to the song.
Yep.
So because you had these two linear solutions,
does that mean you can sort of generate himself?
Yes,
I'm coming to that in a minute.
I'm first doing a more modest goal of showing that there is some is also a
solution.
The second term,
I get Omega Zero Square times x one plus x two equals to zero
your standard does equation look this plus this implies what I've written down
simply by adding,
let's say in words what you've found out,
what you found out that of x one satisfies the equation extra,
satisfies the equation.
X One plus x two let's call it x plus x one plus x two also satisfies the
equation and the proof is right in front of you and the key was the did ever do
offer some somewhat the derivatives.
Now I'm going to generalize it more and say suppose that multiplied all of the
first equation by a all of the second equation by B.
Well that's certainly still true,
right?
You take z something equals zero multiply both sides bay,
it's still going to be zero.
Now imagine adding this to this,
add this to this and what do you get?
You will find these square over DT square off x one plus B x two last Omega Zero
Square x one plus B x two zero
so here's the punchline.
You should give me a two solutions to this equation.
I can manufacture it.
Another one by taking the first one times any number I like less the second one
times any other number I like,
so the story is a lot more detailed,
more complicated than it looked.
It looked like that or two solution actually there's infinite number of
solutions because you can pick a and B any way you like.
So linear equations typically have infinite number of solutions and you build
them up by taking a few building blocks.
They're like,
they're like unit vectors I.
N.
G.
You can take any multiple of this unit back to anyone over that unit vector and
this combination but also solve the equation
just so you don't think there's going to happen all the time.
Let me remind you,
you don't have to write this down but at least follow what I'm saying.
Suppose this quantity here was not x one but the squared of x one and here,
okay,
don't have to write this because this is not a linear equation.
We are not interested in this,
but notice this is nonlinear and you guys should be able to pick it up.
It's not linear because I've got the square of the unknown.
Now can you see if I add these two equations,
but again a and B,
let them both be one.
I get x one squared plus x two square,
but that does not equal to x one plus x two the whole thing square.
So even though they did have it the second day to two of the summer,
the summer,
the second database to the sum of the squares is not the square to the sun.
So for nonlinear equation,
you cannot add solutions.
For linear equation,
you can combine solutions with arbitrary coefficients.
That's the lesson you have learned today.
So I would,
harmonic oscillator equation is a linear equation,
so feel free to combine them and get the falling solution.
X of t is equal to a e to the I Omega is the Roti.
Less B minus I omega is,
you don't have t a and B or whatever you like,
but Omega zero is the original fruit of or whatever.
But if I gave you this solution,
uh,
we'll be happy to take it as a solution for the mass spring system.
And if not,
what is it you don't like?
Yes.
Anybody have a view?
I mean,
would you take that as a good solution?
Yes.
Um,
we need to figure out how to use the right Amy,
are you in order to achieve what?
Uh,
well,
because your system starts some
sample too.
Well,
he's raising a point,
let me repeat his point.
A and B of course,
cannot be in general are arbitrary for this mass.
In this brain you can pick any a and B you like,
but on a given day,
when you pull it by nine centimeters and release it,
that answer has to be chosen so that our t equals zero x becomes nine and the
velocity,
let's say was zero.
We released it.
So when you take the data,
we'll do this in the last year,
should banish fatigue,
will dissolve art.
Maybe it'll have some other velocity when you can fit initial coordinate initial
velocity,
the two numbers by picking these two numbers,
you understand that.
But that's not enough.
I got another problem.
Yes,
it has imaginary numbers.
that's your bother.
You
Great.
The answer it is manifestly not real.
Okay.
And we know x is a real function that is not a mathematical requirement of the
equation,
but the physical requirement that the venue Paula mass nine centimeters and you
release it,
it's going to oscillate with some real x,
x and not a complex sex.
So you gotta fix that.
So to say that x is real,
really means the following.
You remember in the complex world of complex numbers,
a complex number x plus y has a complex find to get explained to y and the
property of real numbers is that when you take the complex conjugate,
nothing happens because I goes to minus PSI.
If the number was purely real,
it satisfies the condition.
Z equals z star.
Serial numbers are their own complex funding gates in general,
a complex number.
It's not his own kind.
You get out if you want me to draw your picture,
that's whereZ is.
That's where does he started is the fellows on the x axis have the properties.
Z is the same as the star is.
He started said reflection or the z axis of the on the x axis of z and therefore
the number is real.
It's its own reflection,
so I'm going to demand that this solution in addition to satisfying the basic
equation also is real.
The dude that I'm going to find the complex conjugate,
it's denoted with the x star of tea.
Now you want to kind to get everything in sight.
The complex ones you get at a,
I'm going to call a star,
appliques going to get an e to the I.
Omega t is either the miners Iomega zero t y because the eye goes to minus Psi
Omega Zito and Trel numbers.
Nothing happens to them and be becomes the star and this becomes either the plus
Iomega zero t
and I demand that these two fellows at equal,
yeah,
if they're both equal,
then I take this exponential and demand that those be the same.
That means I demand that he be the same as B stock.
If it's the same as B star,
this will go into this and then I will demand that be it's the same as a star.
If these conditions are satisfied,
x will become x.
So the trick is to take the function,
take its complex con to get equal to itself and look at the consequence.
Now I want to tell you that it is equal to be star.
Then you don't have to worry about this as an extra condition
because I am your complex conjugate.
You are my complex going to get because the way it works is if it took a and
change every eight to minus sigh right out.
If it took be whatever it's complex form was Jane item minus I you get a but if
it do it one more time,
you come back to where you are.
In other words,
for any complex number,
if you started and you started one more time,
you'll come back to Betty.
What that photo of a is equal to be star.
Take the complex conjugate of the left hand side.
You will find a start is equally be star star,
which is B.
So you don't need these two conditions.
You do need a equal to be star.
Okay?
So you have to put that extra condition.
Now,
so in the real world or people who want a real answer,
you want to write it as a,
even the Iomega Zero t plus a star you can minus Iomega.
Other words be is not an independent.
Number B has to be the complex conjugate of a.
Then all of you can see at a glance that this is now real because whatever this
animal list,
this is the complex conjugate of that.
It's got all the ice turned into minus Ivan.
You add them all the ice cancer answered with video real,
but a is not necessarily real.
The complex number a,
which is some complex number,
it has a length and it can have a face because every complex number can be
written in this form.
Okay?
So if you remember that,
then you find x looks like
absolute value of a youth in the eye,
Omega Zero t plus Fi plus absolute value a the minus Omega Zero t plus Fi.
I mean,
I didn't,
let me go see Dorothy.
Well,
maybe that's too fast for you.
So let me repeat what I did in the place of a right.
The absolute value of times,
either the IFI,
it,
the I five will come by and eat the Iomega Omega t and formed this exponential
second trend would be just the kind you get of the whole thing.
You don't even have to do
no.
What does this function I have,
I want you to think about it.
Do you recognize this?
Greeted here?
Is something familiar now?
Yes.
You have any idea?
Yeah.
Yep.
Hello,
Dan.
Yeah.
You would remember this great identity.
Where is it here?
Uh,
this one
[inaudible] e to the minus I it as two times square sign data.
So this becomes
two times absolute value of a sin Omega t plus Fi and you,
if you want,
you can call to a,
another number C corps saying Omega Zero T.
That's fine.
The second one is,
uh,
not a,
that stepdad representation is a star.
Oh,
but put any complex now you can pull the,
certainly this number out of both.
Yes.
You pull it out.
Then you've got either the ice something plus e to the minus nine [inaudible].
So this is a long and difficult way to get back the old lancer.
You got this by fiddling around and guessing and arguing physically.
But I wanted to show you that with exponential function you will have come to
this answer it anyway.
So your point of view is,
you know,
we don't need this.
I've got no problems in life.
We're lean very well with core science.
Thank you.
Why do you bring this exponential on us?
Well now I'm going to give you a problem where you cannot talk your way out of
this by just trying to get into word problem.
The word problem,
I meant we asked the word question,
find me a function with a second.
Deliberative looks like itself and you can eat the star,
the exponentials and different twice or science and coastline.
So you don't need exponentials.
But look at the following problem.
This is a problem of a mass m forced constant k moving on a surface.
But friction,
the minute you've got friction,
you have an extra force.
So you find an x double dot equals minus K x,
but to the old force due to the spring friction also exerts a force which has
got some coefficient B,
but it's multiplied by the velocity.
We know that it can move into the right,
the forces,
the left we moving to the left of forces,
the right frictional forces velocity dependent.
So the equation you want to solve when you got friction,
it's really Amex double.plus B x.
Dot.
Ah,
plus K X equals zero.
I'm going to do write everything by em.
Take that avenue.
What did here and put it here.
Then I'm going to read it for us.
The equation we want to solve with friction XW
plus Gamma X.
Dot.
Let's Omega zero squared.
X equals zero but gamma this just be over there.
Let's take a question you want to solve.
Can you solve this by your usual word problem?
It's going to be difficult because you want to function,
which when I take two derivatives
looks like the function plus some or multiple zone database.
They cost Omega t it won't do it.
If he takes sign him.
I tea it won't do it.
So we can still solve it.
Because even this equation you solve by the same mindless approach,
which is to say,
let x look like a,
you're the Alpha team
and it'll work.
Let's see how it could work.
It has to work.
You can see why.
Because when I take two derivatives of x,
I would get out for square.
Let me pull the air out of everything.
Plus Alpha Gamma Omega Zero Square,
you're the Alpha t equal to zero.
So what we learned is yes,
that our solutions of this form to this equation,
once again,
it can be whatever number you like because if a vanishes,
you kill the whole solution,
you'd,
the Alpha is not going to vanish should every instant in time.
So the only way is for this to vanish.
That means Alpha that you put into this yes is not any old number,
but the solution at this quadratic equation,
Alpha squared was alpha.
Gamma Plus Omega not squared equals zero.
So do you want Alpha Square?
What does Alpha Gamma is?
Omega squared equals zero Alpha must be the root of this equation.
And we all know the quadratic equation.
We'll have two routes and we will get to solutions and we can add them with any
coefficient you like.
That'll also be a solution.
So let me write it down.
So in other words,
I'm going to explicitly solved this quadratic equation.
So go back to the old days and remember that the solution of that equation will
be alpha equals minus gamma less than minus square root of gamma square minus
four Omega Naught Square over to,
I would like to rewrite this as minus gamma over two plus or minus square root
of gamma over to square minus will Megan r square
and let's call the two routes,
one with a plus sign in one with a minus sign as Alpha plus and minus.
This is a shorthand for this whole combination.
Do you understand that?
If I gave you the mass and the spring constant and I give you the Coefficient of
friction,
the number B Alpha plus Alpha minus that uniquely know you will get too precise
numbers coming out of this whole game and your answer then to this problem.
But we accept t is any number a times e to the minus Alpha plus t any number v
times either the minus Alpha minus d,
but Alpha plus and minus are these two numbers.
I want you to notice what numbers are falling exponentials.
Very important because now I'm talking about a mass,
but I pulled the spring.
That's a lot of friction and I let it go.
I don't want an exponentially growing answered.
That makes no sense.
The extruder eventually vanish and that will in fact happen.
Let's make sure you understand that.
Look at these two routes,
minus gamma over two
plus and minus.
Well that is this solution minus gamma warbird blue square minus Omega,
not square.
I'm going to assume in this calculation that GAM over two is bigger omega not.
Let's do that first.
Then you can see that that's a negative number.
That's a negative number.
The whole thing is negative.
So Alpha minus is definitely,
uh,
let me see how it worked.
It,
oh,
I'm sorry.
I made a mistake here.
I think,
uh,
these are called just plus and minus.
Alpha.
Alpha is two roots and I have to write them as they are.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
So please remove this unwanted sign there because they are the two answers for
Alpha.
So I put either the Alpha plus t so again,
I should change my answer here.
I'm really sorry about this one.
I should write the desk now.
I'm going to write it below so you have a second chance.
So here's what it looks like.
A
either the minus a Yam over two plus square root of GAM over to square minus
omega,
not t square,
t
plus B e to the minus GAM over two minus a GAM.
All were two square minus Omega,
not squared.
T.
Yep.
Pardon me.
I've got the mind,
uh,
I think I didn't mean this or did they get it wrong?
These are the two values of Alpha.
So they both have the first number to be minus gamma over to,
and the square root comes to the plus sign for one of them and minus sign for
the other one.
I probably have a and B mixed up.
Let me check that.
Uh,
well I think even that's okay.
Yes,
I'm willing to be corrected if I got a and B mixed up.
I know these are correct.
I want to make sure this is what I call B B as a coefficient Alpha minus,
which would be this one.
Uh
Oh yes.
Yes.
So what's your day to call this a call?
This be,
how is that now?
Let's see if that works out.
They should be be either the alpha minus t be the minus GAM over too.
Uh,
minus there.
Yes.
Pardon me.
Oh wait,
no.
Okay.
The point of writing it this way is to show you that both these powers,
this is clearly a positive number,
so it's either the minus a negative number.
I just want to show you that this object,
that's all I wanted to emphasize inside the square brackets.
Also possible because this is game over to,
you can see this is a number of smaller than GAM over to square.
If you take this way too of that number will be smaller than GAM over two.
So this cannot overturn the sign of this.
It'll still be a positive overall.
Sandy be negative.
So if you draw the picture here,
it's a summer off to exponentials.
Really just die down after awhile.
Yeah.
And how do I find a and B to find a and B?
What have to do is to take extra data.
One of the maybe initial position x of zero is given to me.
Excess zero has given to me as some number.
I take the solution,
I'd put t equal to zero and have it matched this if a boutique will the zero.
Well all this exponential manage and I just get a plus B because either the zero
is one
essay already had one condition on a and B.
There some must be the initial position.
How broad uh,
initial velocity,
go back to this x and dig Dxdt.
What do you get?
The XD t is Alpha blessed,
Eh,
you're the Alpha plus t plus Alpha minus v.
You're the Alpha minus t they did ever do with my answer is this evaluated at
teak equals the zero
Arctic zero 14 zero.
Here you find x dot of zero
equal to Alpha plus a plus Alpha minus B.
So here are the two equations you need to find a and B,
solve these two simultaneous equations.
In other words,
I will tell you the initial position and I'll tell you the initial velocity
you will take.
Then this number Nolan and that number known,
these are linear,
simultaneous equation for a and B.
You fiddle around in Salford NB,
yes.
Ah No.
We have to ask the following question
in this problem.
If everything is real.
See previously what happened is when I took the complex conjugate of this
function,
the kind to get turned in and the other function and the kind you get at that
function turned back into this one.
That's why a and B were related by complex.
My education here,
if I take the complex conjugate of x,
either the Alpha plasty,
if it's real domains itself,
so eight this goes into a star vehicles in the beast star and you want the
answer to be on chain.
That requires a started be,
it could be stuff.
Thanks for pointing out that here we do want a equal to a star and be equal to B
stuff.
So what I'm telling you is go take the solution conjugated and equated to itself
at remember that now that is exponential remains real to begin with.
So it doesn't go into anything remains itself.
And I compared this exponential before and after its coefficient that went from
a to a star.
They have to be equal.
So asa starting BSB store?
Yes.
Why?
Well look at these functions.
There is no complex numbers here.
That's why everything is real.
So what problems have I solved?
No.
First I put gamma equal to zero,
no friction.
And I just read the drive,
the harmonic oscillator.
Casa may got the minus five plus five then I took a problem with friction.
Then I got a solution that will just exponentially falling because even though
it looks like Alpha plus,
that's a negative number.
That's a negative number.
In the end,
both are falling.
So they will you,
it says you pulled the mass and let it go.
It'll relax to its initial position.
It'll stop.
But all of you must know that there's got to be something in between.
The one case,
have a mass that isolates whatever other cases have a mass.
When I pull it out,
let it go,
goes back to the equilibrium and Rita's zero I'd infinite time,
but we all know that the real situation you run into all the time,
when you pull something,
let it go,
it vibrates and vibrates less than,
less than,
than eventually comes to rest.
Where does that solution,
it's got to come out of this thing.
Yes,
that's correct.
So you've got to go back to the roots.
I found four Alpha minus gamma over to less than minus square root of a gamma
over to square minus Omega,
Not Square.
I had taken GAM over to to be bigger than Omega,
not.
So what I did was I turned on friction.
What?
I didn't turn on a small amount of friction.
I turned on a rather hefty amount of friction so that the friction term was
bigger than the Omega Nocturia.
But if you imagine the other limit where you had no friction in a turn on a tiny
amount of friction,
then the tiny gam over two will be smarter than this Omega not of course,
then you've got the square root of a negative number,
right?
So you should really write it as a less take gam over to less than omega.
Not then you will write this as minus gamma or were too.
But I said minus I
famous Omega Notch,
square minus demo worked this way.
In other words,
write this stuff inside as minus of this number now
and take the square root of minus one and write it as I.
So now what are the solutions look like?
They look like x equal to
a even minus GAM over to,
uh,
let me write the exponential.
They feel like a
either the minus GAM over to
t plus I will make up prime t,
but I'm going to call this combination as Omega prime.
That's why we at Omega not,
and I'll make up right
bless.
Be heated.
The minus GAM over two
minus Iomega plain tea.
Okay.
Oh,
eat at the minus gamma.
Gamma t over two is common to both the factors.
You can pull it out.
Imagine pulling this factored out common to the whole expression.
Then you just got to aid the Iomega prime plus B,
the minus Iomega frame.
That's a pretty family or problem.
If you want that to be real,
you want a to be equal,
the complex conjugate of B.
Then you repeat everything I did before,
so I don't want to do that one more time.
You will get some numbers.
See spending either the miners gam over to t times square,
sine omega prime t plus.
You're can add a fi.
Good.
Nice.
Yeah.
Okay,
so what does this look like?
What does this graph look like?
It looks like Casa Omega t,
but it's got this thing in the front.
If gamma vanishes,
then forget the exponential completely.
This is about oscillating mass.
If gamma is Sonata Zito,
imagine there's one part in 10,000 then for the first one second,
this number will hardly changed from one.
Meanwhile,
this word of oscillators some number of times,
but if you wait long enough,
this exponential rate start coming into play,
and the way to think about it is it's an oscillation who's amplitude itself
falls with time.
And if you draw a picture of that,
I think you will not be surprised that if you dry the picture didn't look like
this.
It's called a damped oscillation.
So that's the method by which you describe the three cases.
One is no friction and one is small friction or friction obeying this condition.
When you have oscillatory motion,
who's amplitude damped with time,
then you have the other case where gamma is crossed some threshold than Omega,
naught,
smaller than gamma over too.
Then you get to falling exponentials.
So what do you imagine the mass is doing with no friction?
If you pull it,
let it go white British forever.
That's not very realistic.
If you're trying a tiny amount of friction,
it will do this,
which is very ubiquitous.
We see it all the time.
You pull a swing and you let it go.
After awhile it comes to rest.
This tells you never quite comes to rest because as long as the is finite,
this number is going to be non zero,
but it'll be very small at some point you just cannot see it.
Third option is over debt.
Over damped is when gamma is bigger than Omega,
naught over to then the asset is nothing that oscillates nothing oscillates.
Everything falls exponentially with time.
Daddy should imagine you pull something,
let it go.
It comes slowly and stops.
When you buy your shocks in your car,
the shock absorbers,
they're supposed to damp the vibration of the car.
It's got a spring,
but this suspending the tires,
but it's emerged in some viscous medium,
so that is vibration.
Variations adapt.
So when you hit a bump,
if your shocks are dead,
you vibrate a lot of time and slowly settle down that veneer shock set in this
region when you bought them David and this ratio,
when you bought them,
they were doing this.
Once you hit a bump in,
you overshoot from your normal position,
you come down to zero and you stay there.
Yes,
that's the ideal situation for damp.
All right,
so I'm going to the last topic in isolation,
but is there anything else?
Is there anything here that you need clarification?
Yes.
Ah,
yes.
So Ben Gamla were two equals Omega not this thing vanishes.
And you seem to have only one solution,
uh,
either the minus gamma t over to
you don't have the plus or minus.
Right.
And we sort of knowing every problem that must be to solutions because we should
be able to pick the initial position and velocity at will.
If a solution is only one free parameter,
you cannot pick two numbers at will.
No,
that's the piece of mathematics I don't want to do now.
But what you can show us in that case,
the second solution looks like this.
It's a new function,
not an exponential but tee times than exponential.
We'll solve the equation,
uh,
those who want to see that this is true can put that into the equation and check
other words.
Pick your gamma carefully so that the square root vanishes.
Only a gamma is left.
But that gamma is not independent of Omega.
That gamma is equal to a two omega not for that problem.
You can check that.
That's the solution.
So is that
that a nice waste and more debate that,
but I think I will don't have time to do that.
Yes.
Why was the equal a start here?
I mean here.
Okay.
Take this x demand that when you conjugate it,
nothing should happen.
Okay.
In this particular example,
when Alpha plus Alpha minus the real numbers here,
the Alpha plasty remains EDF publicity.
When you take you get that four h has to a star and be must also remain
invariant when you take the conjugation.
In other words,
if this was an imaginary exponential like in the other problem and you take the
conjugate,
this exponential becomes this guy in that exponential becomes that guy.
Then by matching the solution you can,
you will be able to show,
this must be the kind of get of that.
That must be the kind to get at this,
but if no imaginary exponentials appear each term a separately be real.
Now this is something you will have to think about.
I'm not saying maybe repeating it makes it any clearer,
so what I want you to do is take the x,
take the complex conjugate of x,
equate the two sites.
That's the rule among functions that if you've got either the plus Alpha t,
it's called vision.
Matt should match on both sides and even the minus Alpha t should have Matthew
corporations.
It's like saying when to have actors of equal.
The Coefficient of I should match in the coefficient of deer should match.
There's a similar theorem that if you take a summer of two independent functions
equated to some or to other in the same independent functions,
the coefficient must separately maths.
If you impose that,
you will find what I told you.
Okay.
Now for the really interesting problem,
really interesting problem is this,
I got the mass,
I got the spring,
I got the fiction,
but I'm going to apply an extra force f not cosine,
Omega t
this Scott,
a driven oscillator.
So far,
the oscillator that was not driven,
in other words,
no one is pushing and pulling it.
If you,
of course you pulled it in the beginning and you released it,
but once you released it,
no one's touching the oscillator,
the only forces on it or due to internal frictional forces or spring force.
But now I want to imagine a case where I am actively driving the oscillator by
my hand exerting a costly and Omega t force.
So Omega here is the frequency of the driving force.
Okay?
That's where that has so many Omegas in this problem.
The Omega Prime that you saw here,
it's not going to appear too many times.
It's a matter of convenience to call this Omega prime,
but this will make,
I will up here all the time when I write an Omega with no subscript is the
frequency of the driving force and the equation we want to solve is x
double.plus Gamma X.
Dot.
Plus Omega nod squared,
x equals f over em because I divided everything by am of course,
Saint Omega t
yeah,
so we've got to solve this problem.
No,
this is really difficult because you cannot get the answer to this by word
problem.
No,
you can do the following.
If the right hand side had been eat the Iomega tea instead of costing me got
the,
you'd be fine because you can pick an x.
They look like either the Iomega t than men you take to deliver this to look
like the Omega t one day to look like Edi,
mega t exit,
exit a look like Udi Omega t.
You can cancel it on both sides,
but what you have is costs Omega t
so here just what people do.
It's a very clever trick.
People say,
let me manufacture a second problem.
Nobody gave me this problem.
Okay,
this is the problem you gave me.
I make up a new problem.
The answer to with is called why.
Yeah,
but why is the answer to the falling problem?
The driving force is sine Omega t
this is what you give me
salt.
This is my artifact.
I introduced a new problem you did not give me,
but I want to look at this problem.
No,
here's the trick.
You multiply this equation,
but any number is still going to satisfy the question.
Let me multiply by what am I here,
put an I here,
put an I here than I here.
Multiply both sides by and add them.
Then I have got x plus y double.plus Gamma at times X.
Dot.
Plus I.
Dot is Omega Notch quit and x plus y,
y.
Let's introduce a number Z which is x plus y.
It varies with time.
That is the question.
By adding the tweak question look like z double dark plus Gamma Z.
Dot.
Let's Omega Not Square.
Z is f what?
M e to the I omega.
T
so I've manufactured a problem in which the thing that's vibrating is not a real
number.
The force driving it is also not a real number.
It's the cause of Omega t plus Ice Sine Omega t,
but if I can solve this problem by some trick at the end,
what do I have to do?
I have to take the real part of the answer because the answer will look like a
real part and an imaginary part.
I left her dump the imaginary part.
That'd be the answer to the question I posed.
Imaginary partner,
but you put the answer to the fictitious bus question I post.
Now,
why am I doing this?
The reason is the following.
If the driving forces eat the Iomega tea,
I can make the following.
Anzar said guests z,
some constant fames eat the I Omega t
I will show you.
Now solutions of this form do exist because let me take that assumed form and
put it into this equation.
Then what do I get?
I get minus Omega,
Square Z,
not either the Iomega t because to deliver this of Edi,
Omega t give me Iomega Times Iomega then one day,
what is it gives me iomega times gamma timesi not eat the Iomega t and no
derivatives just leaves it alone.
If the Iomega t equals f not over m the Iomega t
so let me rewrite this as follows.
Let me rewrite this as minus Omega Square.
Let's I Omega Gamma Omega Notch Square,
I am z not eat the Iomega t is f over m either the Iomega t
this is what I want to be true.
Well,
Eddi,
Omega,
t,
whatever it is,
can be canceled on two sides because it is not zero.
Anything that's not zero,
you can always cancel and here is the interesting result.
You learn for this equation to be valid.
The Z,
not that you pick here in your guests satisfies the condition.
Z not equals f over m divided by
Megan r squared minus Omega,
square,
bless,
Iomega gamma.
No parts of it may be easy.
Parts of it may be difficult.
Easy part is to take the guests I met and sticking with the equation,
cancel exponentials and get the answer.
What you should understand is x was what I was looking for.
I brought in a partner why and I solve forZ ,
which is exposite.
Y andZ was assumed to take this form
with the amplitude with itself could be complex times either the Iomega,
t z not it looks like this.
Then the Z with the z not eat of the Iomega t looks like f over m.
If the Iomega t divided by this number in the denominator I'm going to call.
I put impedance,
I it's called impedance
and there's the falling complex number or make an r squared minus Omega Square
plus I Omega Gamma.
Okay.
We're almost done now,
so,
okay.
TheZ looks like
f not over m e to the I Omega t divided by this complex number.
I imagine this complex number I,
what does it look like?
It's got a real part and an imaginary part.
Imaginary part is I Omega Gamma.
The l part is Omega,
not square minus Omega Square.
This is the complex number I
are told the answer to our problem is to find this number Z.
Then take the real part.
Everybody agreed that every complex number I get better than this is absolute
value times either the I fight five,
we're just going to be here.
Yeah,
and I'm going to write it that way because now things become a lot simpler if
you write it that way.
If not over em,
they were the absolute value of I,
you'd the Ifi,
the Iomega t
now this eat the Ifi.
I can delete it here and put it upstairs as minus Ifi.
So let me write it in that form.
Then it's very easy if not over m divided by the magnitude of this I times e to
the I Omega t minus five.
Okay
but I use this angle,
well now that I got Z,
I know how to find x.
X is the real part of Z.
No.
When I look at real pot,
all these are real numbers.
I will keep them as they are if not over m divided by eye.
The real part of this function I hope you know by now it's cost to make a t
minus five
and that's the answer.
The answer to the problem that had originally given to us is the following.
You know the magnitude of the applied force,
the amplitude of the applied force,
you know the mass of the particle.
You need to find this absolute value of ion fi for that.
You construct this complex number whose real parties,
this was imaginary part is Iomega Gamma
than the absolute value of it is just by Pythagoras Theorem or r squared minus
Omega squared squared.
Plus we'll make a squid gamma square
and the phase fi or B is the condition 10 fi musical to Omega gamma divided by
we're going to get an r squared minus Omega Squared Square [inaudible] Square,
Gamma Square.
I'm sorry.
Uh,
it's just the imaginary part over real part.
So this is the answer to the problem that was given to us,
but there's one side point you should notice which is the following.
What are the three parameters in this problem?
Everything is determined in this problem,
fi absolute I all this unknown,
but we know every equation should have two,
three numbers.
You know what they are?
Anybody all,
okay,
let me tell you what the answer to that question is.
I'm saying I can add to this.
The solution I got earlier on without the driving force
because in this problem when I had the right hand side with a driving force,
let me add a zero to that.
That's harmless.
And by superposition principle,
if that force is produced,
that displacement zero will produce,
what would we have seen all morning?
That even when the right hand side,
the zero that are the solutions they got for you,
either the GAM over to,
because omega,
prime,
t,
etc. So you can always add to this what's called a complimentary function,
which is the solution of the equation with no driving force,
which is what we were studying earlier in the class.
But usually people don't bother with this because they all have in them either
the minus gamma t over two.
So if you wait long enough,
this will die out.
This is the only thing that will remain
so early times.
This is not the full answer.
You should add to this,
the answer to when there's no driving force.
And together they formed the full answer and the number's a and B that you have.
There will be chosen to match some initial conditions like initial position,
initial velocity.
Okay,
now it's time is up.
I'm going to stop.
So I have not been able to finish some parts of this,
so I'm trying to see what I can do.
Uh,
I had asked for you to give this problem set to me on Noah.
What is this today on Wednesday,
right?
So you don't have enough time.
I mean,
I haven't taught you a few other things.
You need about five minutes more of works.
I don't want to keep you back.
Here's what I will do.
I will post on the website some notes on just the missing part here so you can
read it and you can do one or two problems.
You may not be able to do without that.
Then I will come on Wednesday and I will teach that to you again,
but you'll be able to hand in your problems.